SPEAKER 1: Building cloud-native
applications can often
be difficult. Setting up
the right environments,
accessing client libraries,
and figuring out an easy way
to deploy and debug your
application is time consuming.
To help you solve
these challenges,
we built Cloud Code.
Cloud Code is a
set of IDE plugins
that allows you to
write, deploy, and debug
cloud-native applications
quickly and easily.
Cloud Code supports
a number of IDEs,
including Visual Studio
Code, JetBrains IDEs
such as IntelliJ, and
Cloud Shell Editor.
This way, you can leverage
the tools you already know.
Let's dive deeper into how Cloud
Code helps you write, deploy,
and debug your code faster.
First, a collection of
starter templates showing
best practices in a
variety of languages
are available out
of the box, and you
can run these on Google
Kubernetes engine
or Cloud Run with
just a few clicks.
As you build out your app, you
can easily enable and integrate
numerous Google Cloud
APIs from your IDE.
You can also leverage
Cloud Code's Secret Manager
integration to access and
manage sensitive data, like API
keys, passwords,
and certificates
right from your IDE.
And if you aren't someone
who loves writing YAML files,
Cloud Code improves your
YAML authoring experience
with features like Code Snippets
and In-line Documentation.
Once you're done
writing your code
and those pesky YAML
files, it's time to deploy.
If you're trying to run
your Kubernetes application
on a local Kubernetes
cluster, Cloud Code
makes it easy to deploy
to Docker Desktop
or will create and start
a minikube cluster for you
if you don't have one.
When developing, Cloud Code
can automatically rebuild
and redeploy your code every
time you make a change.
It even supports hot
reloading individual files
that change to the container
without a rebuild or redeploy,
so you see updates
in under a second.
Even better, Cloud Code works
with any Kubernetes cluster,
be it on Google Cloud
or any other cloud.
After deploying, you
may discover issues
in your application.
Cloud Code is here to help by
providing the same debugging
experience you're
used to in the IDE,
even when debugging a
remote Kubernetes cluster
or a serverless application.
Just place breakpoints,
then debug your code
in your Kubernetes cluster or
locally on Cloud Run emulator.
If you need to dive
deeper, Cloud Code
also comes with a
built-in log viewer
to help you monitor
and debug issues
with your Kubernetes
and Cloud Run services
right within your IDE.
Now you know how
Cloud Code works
to improve your
experience creating
cloud-native applications
within your favorite IDE
by helping you write, deploy,
and debug your code faster.
We hope this short
introduction to Cloud Code
gives you all you
need to get started.
Cloud Code is the
most productive way
to build cloud-native
applications.
And you can give it a try by
going to cloud.google.com/code.
Also, you can reach
out to us via Slack.
You can find us using this link
with #cloud-code as the channel
name.
[MUSIC PLAYING]